at the studios of the movie Giants the
gates remain locked the lights and the
cameras are out of action Tinseltown has
become a ghost town an industry that
employs hundreds of thousands like so
many now in suspended animation for
actors this is usually audition time
with no shows to make two British actors
in Hollywood have started their own it
fills the need for a creative outlet
they say because normal service in
Hollywood is some way off what you can't
is you can't rush scripted content
there's a process at the rightest room
and then developing the script and a
story and then there's a casting and the
shooting and then there's the editing
you can't just gallop through that to
catch up so people just have to
understand there's going to be a little
bit of a a sort of gap in that market
before their favorite shows and movies
can resume I was thinking about when we
do go back and like well if you've got
to kiss someone in a scene I mean
there's just you know our industry we
are so all up in each other's business
all the time even just when we're on set
you've got hair and makeup people
breathing on you and touching you and
when Sean and I were on once upon a time
it took one person to have a chest
infection we all had a chest infection
like even when you go to sit and you
touch the stage door we've all touched
that door the movies are coming back
this road rage thriller starring Russell
Crowe is being released early the first
since the lockdown the producer says a
response to public demand we are most
definitely the canary in the coal mines
it has become and I think part of the
reason for that is there's hope right
because this is one of those steps that
we all need to take toward the theaters
that are half full with social
distancing but these are all the steps
we need to take for it to be safe and it
feels better than standard Oh
those at home have prompted record
demand for TV companies but viewers are
likely to see disruption I mean what may
end up happening is that there's a
greater tolerance for kind of low five
productions sort of zoom concerts like
like the one Lady Gaga did or the
Stephen Sondheim birthday it seems like
in times in these times people are a
little more willing to to watch things
that that don't have a kind of a shiny
veneer hollywood's always offered
escapism but even here sometimes real
life is the greatest drama greg Milam
Sky News Los Angeles